[Music]
how do you shift gears to get out of i
am the same things that make me
successful at my work
to now i'm a mom now i'm a wife no i'm a
friend so one of the exercises i went
through and this actually came out of
untrained leadership summit last year my
talk for that so that was before i wrote
this book okay i wrote this talk this is
the background to it
um
i think asking people if you tell people
you know
figure out what matters and spend your
life on those things which is
essentially what i'm saying in this book
and showing you the steps to do it that
can be hard people say well what does
matter what's important to me what what
do i want for my life they don't know
right
so i said what if you ask a different
question and i asked this on stage and
it really resonated
and then it's something i've been doing
too
instead of saying what do i need to do
what do i need to spend my time on you
know what are my priorities what do i
want all that stuff
which can be really hard to answer
especially when you're busy and you're
in the weeds instead ask yourself a
different question
who do i want to be
who do i want to be to my kids
and when i it's almost this out of body
experience of like saying like looking
at myself more objectively instead of
who do i think i am i think i'm failing
i think i'm this whatever it's like no
who do i want to be
and and that's another common thing i
have seen from at least the women that i
work with they say things all the time
like i'm not a fun mom i'm not a
business owner i'm not a runner and all
i can think is says who go do something
fun and boom you're a fun mom go put
your idea out there go run it into the
street you can fix this right now
so instead of thinking about like who do
you think you are
and living within those labels we put on
ourselves or those limitations we think
we have then instead just say what who
do i want to be and so when i wrote a
list of who i want to be to my kids
that then determines what i do when i
get home because then i
act like the person i want to be so if i
want to be happy if i want to be fun if
i want to be present if i want to then i
act out of that intention of that what i
decided i wanted to be and then what's
interesting is i become that because our
actions determine who we are so it's
like i choose
who i want to be and act in line with
that and then i just
by default become that and it's not
perfect at all no but it but it's it's
directional but if i don't decide that i
will come home i'm like well we're doing
this and then this and then this and you
need to get fix your clothes like i
would be drill sergeant because at work
i'm so switching gears so fast now i've
got to do this now i've got to write i'm
so task oriented at work and we run so
hard and fast here
that like i would not
be present in the moment with my kids i
would not be able to enjoy the
spontaneity enjoy the when my when my
son takes i don't know seven and a half
hours to walk down the stairs which i'm
like how could you move slower an actual
snail could be beating you right now
like but it forces you to slow down and
just be with them in their world and
what's important to them and what sounds
fun to them versus your ideas about what
should be important and whatever so i
think that question has really helped me
who do i want to be and i can do you can
do the same thing at work you can do it
anywhere who do i want to be i read a
book this weekend and it was fascinating
um
and they talked about there's two
different brain circuits and and i hate
to use those tech or mechanistic
metaphors for humans but
so when you use the word i
i am i am in i am can't believe i said
that okay if i did that i'm late to pick
up my kids again
that that feeling of in it triggers a
fight-or-flight response your cortisol
adrenaline you are in it
when you use words like you
or when you talk to yourself hey christy
you actually solve that problem over
there and it doesn't trigger your
response interesting or when you go
future so
two examples of this i've seen is when
me and sheila are in the middle of
something and i i think what is
happening in my marriage right now and
then i come to work and someone says hey
can you help me me my wife are and i can
go yeah this this and this because when
i'm in it i've got a hormonal chemical
response to this to to fight it or run
from it when i'm over here i'm distance
from it my body can
doesn't unhook my frontal lobe right
right i'm in it i can answer those
questions and what you just said is a w
is a awesome way of distancing yourself
from and it lets you just go
huh i can be a part of this one in this
one and this one otherwise except when
i'm in it i'm gonna start solving this
thing right because i gotta i gotta be i
gotta be fighting it or running from it
or freezing with it and
um it seems like a gentler way right
well it's interesting that you say that
because i think for me one of the things
that is helpful about it is you don't
feel held back by who you think you are
like oh i feel like i feel like i'm
failing or whatever all these things are
but it also just helps you decide that
that you can
you can become that person you can you
can decide who you're going to become
and you can do that and i think that for
a lot of people that feel like
they're not a good mom or they're
failing or whatever that narrative is
not even true but if you can act in line
with whatever you think that is then it
just gives you more permission one of
the things that i talk about
in the book that i'm so guilty of is
sometimes if i'm not careful
i will for example i will focus on the
wrong thing
in any given moment
and and by doing that it not only steals
my sense of balance and all that but it
actually turns me into someone that i
don't like so let me give you an extreme
example
uh last year at christmas i wanted to
like all moms for the record want to get
a picture of all my kids in matching
christmas pajamas in front of the
christmas tree i realize this is a big
ask but i just want to make it happen
okay these dreams are real all the women
can relate right now it's like okay guys
i'm bribing i'm rewarding i'm you're
doing great here we go i they don't even
need to be perfect but just everybody
looking in the general vicinity of
camera oh no oh no 600 attempts
ornaments are flying off conley's kicked
his brother mary grace is screaming
somewhat like it's mass chaos and
because i'm trying so hard
to capture this photo to show what a fun
time we're having
i created a situation that is the exact
opposite of fun right and by the way
turned myself into someone that i don't
like yeah and so
let's use that example separate yourself
from that go
who do i want to be in that moment i
want to be a mom that's like snapping
pictures of what's actually happening
and if we capture one cool like like now
my new photo rule is three i try three
times and i quit if i get it great if i
don't i don't and we move on and those
pictures will be equally if not more fun
to talk about in 30 years 100 right 100
there's a um do you ever watch the show
uh little fires everywhere no okay well
there's a scene reese witherspoon pet
plays elena and there's that exact scene
where she ends up screaming and cussing
at her daughter in front of the
christmas tree this thing that's an
extreme example but we all do it where
we get caught up in things
that we think are important that are not
but because we're so focused on that
obsessed with that spending time on that
energy money whatever that is and you
can fill in the blank with a million
different examples
we become someone we don't like so
instead i just want to decide who i want
to be someone that i would like that i'd
be proud to be and then just what would
that person do how can i act in line
with that idea in my head of who i want
to be versus reacting to
all these unimportant things that i get
caught up in that i think is so easy to
get caught up in i love
so who keeps you accountable to that do
you and matt have a code word
who do you allow into your life that
says chrissy we're done
or do you have that
matt doesn't have to say it he has a
look yeah he has a look does that piss
you off though yes because you're trying
to get your pictures done like yes
i'm like you don't understand you know
what else he does what else you don't
understand he's like i do what are we
doing
we have these codes and he never like he
never like taught me the codes i just
have picked up on the codes after 10
years one of them is a look when it's
like you're being too much like all this
about the christmas like he'll just look
like or he might just go babe
and i know that look it's like it's over
you know what else he does he'll be at
dinner like this i'm like they'll say
group of friends he'll just
gently place his hand on my leg and i
know that means i'm being way too loud
he never told me the hand on the leg
means you're being too loud but i just i
did notice a pattern that i would be a
very loud volume when the hand always
came on my legs i was like okay i'll
just bring it down a notch sheila gives
me the the you're being a lot for
everyone it's just a it's a pressure on
my shoulder and it's just like
hey
hey and that's uh all the things come
out of your mouth you're gonna regret
tomorrow
and um i don't even think you're you're
with us matt is so brilliant cause he
didn't have to say a word yeah it's just
it's a it's a look or it's a hand on my
leg and like i know the first 15 years
that happened i got raged out like
exactly and now i'm like you're exactly
right i'm sorry yeah well like if i when
i you know i don't know need to
rearrange our side tables or throw
pillows for the 400th time i'll be like
bam i think they look great i'm like
that's right
see and i would tell matt to take a dive
on that one like let's let him let him
ride dude that's right
one time he came to the store this is a
few months ago he came downstairs and i
go do you like that side table he goes i
do i also liked numbers 4 7 19 and 29.
i liked all of those every
all the options we've had rotating
through the last few months okay so what
makes you a good mom
what makes you good at momming
can i give you two things you can give
as many as you want
there are two things i really pride
myself in that i think is just i think
will matter later i hope it does because
i'm really trying hard at it
being present i know we've talked about
that but like i'm with them
i'm in it yeah i'm in it like whatever
story you're telling me like i'm i'm
winning in it
also being fun
like their version of fun so like i'm
not a sit back and watch them play i am
in it like i am like we are making up
games and scavenger hunts and building
forts out of cardboard boxes like i'm
super creative so i just
i just i just want to be
what makes you a good wife
like a good partner for matt
i
okay i encourage
anything he wants to do now granted the
caveat to that is he doesn't ask for
much so if he's like i want to take a
guy's trip i'm like yes go golf yes buy
the fancy smoker grill yes yes yes like
the smoker i don't know what is it
called the komodo whatever that is
i just i anything he wants
and he makes it easy because he doesn't
hardly ask for anything you know what i
mean so it's sometimes like you should
you know like
i just i really i really try to
encourage and affirm him he's one of
those people that like he's always like
puts everybody's needs before his own
he's a deep sense of responsibility like
that would be your responsibility please
go go run on do the trail running group
go on a guy's trip go golf go
yeah i just but but i that goes both
ways i i want to be able to do that and
i want him to be able to do that i want
us both to have a healthy
other parts of our lives than just each
other and home responsibilities all the
time what's what then you're trying to
get better at being a mom
um
typical enneagram eight but my anger
like
i'm not proud of that but man when
you're tired and like they're just
screaming and they're just wiping peanut
butter on the walls
the walls you just clean yeah yeah
or my son conley will just like go
through a room and literally just like
throw everything on the floor like with
bookshelves anything just like just it's
like they're just actual tornadoes and
and and most of the time i'm like like
you know you read all these parenting
books and they're like well just like
you know just ask them how they're
feeling i'm like
i wanna hear how they're feeling i
just every now and then i'll snap and
i'll just scream
so do you get do you get angry at
what they did do you get angry at
that you had a picture of what this was
going to look like and now it's
different like what do you get angry at
because i find myself there too
and
what what do you what do you what does
that
that thing come from or is it just a
it's your kids demonstrate how little
you actually control in the world like
what what's the anger for all all of the
above option d all of the above but i
will tell you the one that is the most
maddening to me
is undoing work i've done and i think
that's because i'm so tired and so like
when i'm really tired and i pick up you
know all the toy whatever and they come
through and literally just throw it all
out
like that that's maddening because i'm
like i was so tired and and and dug so
deep to be able to do that whatever the
thing is fill in the blankets whatever
it is you know you could be any number
of things it's not just cleaning it's
not just toys it's like anything like
i'll i'll get cart you know get colleen
all dressed for the day and the next
thing i know he's literally just like
wiping you know yogurt on his shirt i'm
like
the whole thing yet that's right
yep
that that that that cuts me deep because
i'm just like i have to do it like it's
it's you go insane because you're like
i'm doing the same thing and getting the
same results over and over and over
again but i don't want to i'm trying to
do something new but they just and i
find myself trying to do
explain algorithms and there's a child
going huh yeah like i don't what and you
have to go oh you're five or you're
three you don't know what i'm talking
about right